gli incontri brutte di davide cerullo
è il primo della sua famiglia ad entrare
nella malavita organizzata a 10 anni
vende droga ed è ricercato dalla polizia
a 14 anni guadagna cifre notevoli
vendendo la morte e riceve in regalo la
sua prima pistola la sua piazza e
scampia dove vende rowena bianca fumo e
cocaina a 16 anni il primo arresto al 17
un conflitto a fuoco con clan rivali è
cresciuto con il piacere del crimine da
grande voleva fare il camorrista a 18
anni il primo arresto da maggior l
poggio reale li scopri un libro e
succede qualcosa
questo è il peggio di davide cerullo
adesso facciamoci raccontare da lui il
meglio
e sì bisogna proprio
fare giustizia per certi posti e lo devo
dire non possono farlo e io commesso dei
reati
e questo è importante saperlo non l'ho
fatto perché
sono nato a scampia
ma poteva nascere anche qua e fare e
compiere le stesse cose probabilmente
perché scampia non è solo a scampia è
successo quello che mi è successo perché
non ho avuto gli strumenti necessario
per potermi difendere
guardate che è fondamentale pensare e ve
lo dice uno che ha fatto fino alla
quinta elementare e io a scuola ci
volevo andare e voi melo insegnate che
l'istruzione è il più grande atto di
democrazia e di libertà
se manca sei fregato perché è molto
difficile
difficilissimo
che chi legge
poesia
difficilmente può essere
ingabbiata in qualsiasi potere non solo
quello malavitoso
io sono stato riesumato dalla poesia
c'è qualcosa di molto più forte
dell'infelicità della disperazione e
questa è la speranza
e allora c'è stato bisogno
io sono felice di poter sentire forte
quasi prepotentemente dentro la certezza
che lo stesso di più forte e questo è
importante e importante per tutti
noi si possono rubare il cellulare la
borsa il denaro e masci sa una cosa
d'angelo a rubare su
e la parola la parola la forza sanitario
della parola che io dove la vado a
scoprire nel posto meno
meno meno possibile
nel buio di una cella del carcere di
poggioreale a napoli
forse il peggiore carcereri napoli
proprio lì nel fatica un avellino stanza
31 tornando da allora dare dove eravamo
25 persone che era la stanza più grande
trovo sul mio lettuccio un libro in
libro che racconta la storia del più
grande e psicoanalisti di tutti i tempi
gesù
è lì dentro spogliandolo trovo il mio
nome davide perché la malavita mi aveva
tolto pure il nome
io mi riconsegno il nome davide avere il
proprio nome significa avere la propria
identità
significa poter citare la direzione per
la propria strada per il proprio
cambiamento
c'è stato un giudice perché io poi ha
scambiato tornato sotto nato perché ho
sentito forte di mettere in campo la mia
quota di responsabilità c'è stato un
giudice non lo so se ve lo ricordate
si chiamava paolo borsellino
ha detto una cosa bellissima
che l'ha detta sua sorella il palermo
non mi piaceva poi ho capito
bisogna amare ciò che non ci piace per
poterlo cambiare
bellissimo
io non voglio sentirmi staccato da voi
dal vostro territorio perché scampia non
è sola scampia
anche qua avete sicuramente la vostra
piccola scampia
pensate che noi
e proprio vero nasciamo più italia
incontri che facciamo che dai libri che
leggiamo ea me c'è stato è stato
necessario un incontro e un incontro con
una persona che viene proprio da bene
una suora su armonica ridolfi una donna
pazzesca una donna che non aveva paura
di sporcarsi con quella realtà una donna
che era convintissima che gli
irrecuperabili non esistono solo solo
un'invenzione della nostra cattiva
volontà non esistono cattive ragazze
cambiate il modo di vedere buttati giù
il velo di cataratta verso scampia
se continuate a vederla e a conoscerla
solo per sentito dire o all'immagine che
vi arrivano attraverso gomorra
difficilmente riusciamo a creare la
relazione
c'è stata una
una donna la nonnina che andava
all'ospedale a trovare la sua nipotina e
un certo punto storico tina stava male
la nonna fa amore di nonna frega prega
pregadio
e la nipotina fa nonna ma dio non esiste
e la nonna dice e tu fallo esistere
bisogna ritornare a farli esistere la
bellezza
bisogna tornare a farli esistere il
senso dello stupore di fronte le cose
e i nostri bambini giu hanno bisogno
proprio di essere ri ambito i loro che
hanno bisogno di riabituarsi alla
bellezza è su questo che dobbiamo
lavorare di male di di traumi al mondo
ce ne sono già troppi noi abbiamo una
tremenda responsabilità verso il nato
fragile perché è nato già un territorio
francia e quindi noi cosa facciamo
ecco perché ci stiamo incontrando adesso
per quanto mi riguarda con me ci stiamo
incontrando
perché vogliamo tornare a riscoprire
il giorno a ri abitare il mondo e
abitarlo in una maniera
vogliamo abitare poeticamente il mondo
come il contemplativo
chi è il contemplativo e uno che si
prende cura del mondo
noi dobbiamo ritornare a ripartire a
piantare alberi e vuoi qua lo fate
perché bergamo la conosco bene ho girato
tantissimo
tanti tantissimi giovani impiantano a
ognuno di noi dovrebbe piantare un
albero
oggi noi dobbiamo cantare molto di più
ritornare alla terra io sono tornato giù
e
ho visto che potevo contare molto poco
sulle persone allora sapete cosa ha
fatto ho convocato degli animali un
asinello che si chiama ciro
è molto intelligente
una capra due pecore
le galline e conigli e
un riccio e tante piante
abbiamo recuperato uno spazio
abbandonato
dove non diceva niente perché era
abbandonato quando si abbandona un posto
cosa diventa
si creano di vuote e dentro ci va a
finire di tutte noi abbiamo recuperato
quello spazio verde perché abbiamo
capito che bisognava
ricominciare dalle piante scusate vi
dico una cosa perché voi che avete
subito tanto però
avete pensato che da quanto per il
problema pandemico
la gente ha cominciato a morire e la
natura ricominciata vivi
assisi allora vuol dire che dobbiamo ri
e
riconciliarci con la terra
con quella che forse è l'elemento
migliore per poter capire che cos'è la
vita e anche la morte perché sono due
cose che cammino insieme
allora mi sono messo a pulire ci siamo
messi a pulire insieme ai bambini perché
i bambini hanno capito subito con gli
animali con la terra e con le piante
potevano avere la possibilità lì a
scampia di poter essere dei bambini
questo è fare politica quello che ci
stiamo dicendo adesso secondo me e
prendersi cura del mondo e tornare a
fare il pane
abbiamo bisogno di poeti di gente che sa
più che l'hanno della crescita c'è
bisogno l'anno dell'attenzione
l'attenzione a chi cade a chi cresce
questo senso dell'attenzione verso verso
l'altro che è lo specchio della riuscita
della nostra vita soprattutto se
parliamo di bambini
e allora abbiamo cominciato a pulire
abbiamo sapete che scampia
e molti ragazzi che vengono dal nord
anche da bergamo giù a scampia
si scoprono
arricchite
imparano a vivere lì a scampia dove
sembra che si possa immaginare che si
possa solo morire la non è così
c'è un grado di umanità che non
troverete da nessun'altra parte
e poi e dobbiamo sentirla quella questa
responsabilità di fronte ai bambini
delle scampi e del mondo siamo tutti
responsabili
nessuno escluso nessuno perché noi
diciamo che i giovani sono il nostro
futuro ma come facciamo a dirlo non è
vero se non lo siamo noi come possono
essere loro no quindi dobbiamo
ritornare a har innamorarci ad aprire
gli occhi sul senso della vita
soprattutto per quanto riguarda la
natura gli alberi dobbiamo ritornare a
riscoprire ea riparare il sentimento che
c'hanno verso verso di loro come
comunicano come riesce una pianta che
beve meno dell'altra l'altra che ha più
acqua sotto attraverso le radici di da
acqua
pensate che che poesia da noi è arrivato
un
pioppo io non ho piantato l'ha portato
qualche uccello
pensate che bomba che questa cosa
pensate che meraviglia
abbiamo bisogno di questo abbiamo ma
guarda te permettetemi noi se non
impariamo da quello che ci è successo e
da quello che vi è successo soprattutto
vuol dire che non vuol dire che
l'umanità è qualcosa che non è ancora
avvenuta
e allora
c'è tanta strada da fare bisogna
fermarsi e amen e quando ero nella
malavita mi dicevano chi si ferma è
perduto oggi è vero il contrario bisogna
fermarsi per non perdersi
bisogno di scoprire il giorno pensate
che noi diamo per scontati o solito
sentito qualcuno quando ha cominciato a
piovere qualcuno ha detto ma che
giornata di merda
su subito fasi chissà di giornate volevo
ma no
sembro sul
o meno male
ci sono alcuni posti nel mondo dove
stanno pregando perché viene giù la via
oggi e che non piove capite dobbiamo
rivedere un po di corsa un po di cose e
allora
quando i bambini vengono all'albero
delle storie e io vi invito a venire giù
quando vengono lì non vogliono tornare
più nelle loro case
perché le considerano gabbie come molte
scuole della nostra italia
bisogna riscrivere un pinocchio
all'incontrario che ci sono dei bambini
che vanno che sono normali a scuola
escono che sono dei burattini vi devo
lasciare e vi voglio lasciare con un
pensiero di responsabilità ed è quello
che credo se lottiamo insieme per un
paese migliore
non ho in mente un futuro con più soldi
più macchine più beni di consumo ma una
scuola che sia davvero per tutti una
sanità che funziona per tutti è di buon
livello
un paese che accolga e sostenga chi
viene da guerre e povertà
ho in mente la parità vera tra uomini e
donne
ho in mente gente che si incontra e
decide insieme come crescere con impegno
civile non lotterà e mai per aumentare
il consumo di cose spacciando la
schiavitù ai padroni come democrazia
regalata dalle leggi di mercato
la democrazia è un'altra cosa e
l'impegno a rendere perseguibile
la felicità per tutti
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]